We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David P.
this voicemail came in.
It's a voicemail from a, I don't know that
I would call it a very angry Trumpist, uh,
or a very angry right-winger.
But it is certainly someone who believes we
are wrong about everything and they know everything.
That's a really important element of this
voicemail.
Let's take a listen to it.
Remember you can call anytime and leave a
voicemail.
Two one nine two.
David P is the voicemail number.
Let's listen together.
Uh, yeah, I was watching your videos and man,
I just couldn't tell you how wrong you guys
are.
It's like like an alternate universe.
Hmm.
So poker see at every corner and you guys
just don't see it.
I'd love to point it out for you.
I mean, I could, if you ever had a conservatives
on your show,
we do often
debate.
You know what I mean?
You'd just be pummeled by you and the face
news never really, you know, has anybody on
and it's just crazy.
I mean, you're transgender athlete video.
I mean you're saying we used that issue.
No.
The reason why we talk about it is because
we cannot believe our eyes.
What's happening is this real life or the
Twilight zone?
You guys are an unbelievable,
yeah.
What they're referring to there is, I got
a call, I think it was during a livestream
last week or the week before where I was asked
about this issue of transgender athletes and
participating in this that the other, which
uh, you know, should, should, uh, transgender
individuals participate based on their biological
sex or whatever.
And I said that I, I don't disagree that those
are real questions, but that that is not the
primary issue around trans rights and that
when we're talking about issues of trans rights
and bathroom policy and all of this different
stuff, you know, job employment discrimination,
that bringing up questions about if you're
born biologically male, should you be allowed
to weight lift against other women if you
are a trans woman later in your life.
I'm not saying it's not a question, I'm not
saying it needs to be figured out, but it
is not the forefront of the issue around trans
rights.
And a lot of people were angry.
They said, David, how dare you say that that
issue of men's and women's sports leagues
is not the foremost issue of trans rights?
Well, it's not.
Now as far as you want to debate me, call
in.
We take calls every week on the broadcast
show.
I accept calls typically at least once a week
during an impromptu live stream on either
YouTube or Twitch.
I am glad for you to call in and tell me all
the ways in which you are right and I am wrong.
On the bonus show today, the Donald Trump
campaign has revoked media credentials for
Bloomberg news reporters over a decision not
to investigate 2020 Democrats in a very particular
way that Trump wanted them to do.
We will also talk about Elon Musk of Tesla
fame testifying in his own defense during
this defamation trial over the pedo guy tweet.
If you don't remember that, we'll catch you
up on it.
It is interesting what is going on and we
will also discuss on the bonus show the first
Supreme court gun rights battle in 10 years,
which may have a significant impact on the
legal landscape.
So a lot of really important substantive,
good stories about a freedom of the press,
about the Supreme court gun safety regulations,
and so much more on the bonus show.
Get instant access, one of two ways.
Become a member@joinpacman.com it takes under
a minute.
Become a patron at patrion.com/david Pakman
show also takes under a minute, probably under
20 seconds.
If you already have a Patrion account, you'll
get instant access to the bonus show and that's
where I will next speak to you or otherwise.
We'll be back with a new show tomorrow and
[inaudible]
we didn't coverage of today's Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings in the house judiciary committee,
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].